- Hi everyone.
Welcome to our Daily Homeroom live stream.
This is our way at Khan Academy
of keeping everyone in touch
during school closures.
Obviously as an
organization with a mission
of providing a free world class education
for anyone, anywhere.
We put a huge emphasis on
how do we put our materials together
to support parents and teachers.
We've been running parent
webinars, teacher webinars
and this is really a part of that process.
I do like to remind folks
we are not for profit.
If you're in a position to do so,
please think about making
a donation to Khan Academy.
We were running at a deficit
even before this crisis
and our deficit has
gotten a little bit worse
now that our costs have gone up.
I do wanna give a special thanks to
several corporations
that have helped us out
especially through this crisis.
Bank of America, Google.org,
AT&T, Novartis and Fastly.
They stepped up in really record time
and even with their significant help,
we're still digging into our reserves
in order to be able to do the work we do.
So once again, if you're
in a position to do so,
please think about donating.
So I am super excited
about our guest today
and I see that I'm
freezing up a little bit,
at least on my screen.
Philippe in the background,
let me know if I'm freezing
up a little bit too much
but my guest today is Jim Nondorf,
who is the Head of Admissions
at University of Chicago.
Is that a fair way of describing you, Jim?
And we're gonna be talking
about college admissions
and all the rest.
So I've been told, let
me close my other tabs
that might be slowing down my computer
but so maybe a good
place to start, Jim, is,
tell us how are you in college admissions
at University of Chicago but I'm assuming
it's indicative of a lot of other places.
How are you thinking
about the COVID crisis
and next year's admissions?
- Oh, well we're thinking
about it in a lot of ways.
Obviously the university as a whole
is making plans for
what we can do on campus
and what we will do online.
Currently our students are online
as almost every school that
I can think of is doing.
In terms of the admissions efforts,
we are kinda doubling down and making sure
that all the things that a student needs
to do, to learn about our school,
to learn about how to apply
to highly selective schools,
to write good essays, to
showcase their academic promise,
that all of that is being
communicated to them
in a whole host of ways.
We have opened up so many
different online tours,
info sessions, Spanish
information sessions.
We've got alumni doing work,
we've got tour guide panels
and all of this is not just
about the university of Chicago,
it's really to help all
the students understand,
what do you need to do over
the next six to seven months
to be prepared to apply to any school
and in some odd way they're,
you can actually do more
and be better prepared
to put a great application together
through all the resources
that use coverage.
I know my peers are putting together
for our students.
So, this is not the time to panic.
This is actually the time to
focus on the things you can do,
not what you can't do.
- And I wanna remind all all the viewers,
whether you're on YouTube or Facebook,
put your questions in.
We have team members who are monitoring.
This is your chance to
ask Jim really anything
and I'm happy to answer any questions
that you might have as well.
But Jim, maybe a good place,
as you mentioned, this
isn't the time to panic,
everything's gonna be fine
but we've had previous sessions
where we talked about the SAT and AP tests
and kids were worried about
some tests getting canceled
or they're different this year.
How are y'all thinking
about the test optionality
of things or these new types of tests?
- Sure, so testing and the fact that
students have gone, are online
doing their own high school work
and some of their grading
has gone from letter grades to pass-fail.
All of this is happening
and I wanna assure all the families
that admissions officers do
not have their heads stuck
in the sand or stuck up other places,
which I've been told I do on occasion.
We actually know what's
going on in the world
and we are trying to
accommodate those things.
So, I'll start, I guess with the testing.
So many students have taken tests.
For those students that
haven't taken tests,
there will be testing
available in the Fall.
There's also U.Chicago is test optional.
So we don't require testing.
You can submit your testing
if you've already taken it
and you're good at it
or you could print out some
of the work you've done
on Khan and send that in and say,
and tell us, "Oh, I've
achieved mastery of this."
There's all kinds of tests,
APs, SAT 2s, ACT all of this.
If you've done it and you
wanna submit it, great.
Many schools are going to
be test optional this year.
So some of the flagship state publics,
many of my peers and there's
over a thousand schools
that were already test optional.
For the schools that are still
going to require testing,
I guarantee there will be testing
opportunities in the Fall,
either live in person the way it had been.
I know the SAT, the College
Board is adding test sittings.
And so every month, I
believe beginning in August,
there will be a test sitting
and then if no one is allowed to,
if, through the virus gets worse
and we're all back home
and unable to go to a test center
and take tests with other
people, the SAT will be online.
They have guaranteed that they
will offer an online version.
So whether you're applying to schools
that require testing or
do not require testing,
everything will be fine.
Just continue to study hard, work hard
and do the things you can do,
everything will be...
There's no need to worry about it,
I guess is the best way to say it.
- And we're getting a ton of questions
and I actually want to
get to these questions.
But you mentioned test optional
and I think test optional has always been
a little bit confusing for some students.
What's your read of test optional?
Does it mean if you do
well on the SAT or ACT,
that's great.
What if you didn't do well,
are you at a disadvantage somehow?
- You definitely are not at a disadvantage
applying without testing
to test optional schools.
So the way I think of testing is
it's one way of showcasing
your academic promise.
Some students, instead
of submitting testing,
they submit amazing artwork or music.
I have students who have gotten,
they, have built business plans,
they have patents already,
they run companies.
I have students who just
get a little nervous
about taking testing.
You have students who have
not had access to test prep.
You have students who have,
the worst of all sins,
they did not know about Khan Academy
and so these students,
testing didn't showcase their very best.
The testing does not showcase who they are
and so, send me something
else in lieu of that,
a paper that you're really proud of,
there's no reason to feel,
and every school will tell you this.
Testing is not the be-all end-all.
It can be an important
part of your application,
but it doesn't have to be.
- That's super helpful
and just going with
that theme from YouTube,
Ben QB asks, will you guys
look at AP tests from this year
'cause AP test is clearly
a little bit different.
How are y'all thinking about that?
- We will.
So, we never required
the AP tests in the past
and we will look at them
essentially the same way
we've looked at them.
There are students who have taken the AP
and decided to take the AP online tests,
we'll treat them as valid just
as we did any other testing.
We have crediting policies
for students who were admitted and come
and so, no change in
how we will view the APs
and I think that will be the case
for most of my peers.
Here again, if a student is nervous
about taking their testing online,
I'm sure we will understand,
okay, some students just won't
take the AP test this year
because they were nervous
about doing it online
and we will understand that
and be accommodating for that.
- And I actually wanna
double click on that
'cause there is this perception,
especially with students who
might wanna go to a place
like university of Chicago,
they have these archetypes in their mind.
The kid who gets a five on five AP tests
and then she's the,
gets a 1500 on their SAT
and they do X, Y, and Z.
But some of what you just said,
it isn't that.
You're saying there's other ways,
but I think there might be
people who are skeptical.
They're like, "Well, he's just saying that
"'cause he wants my application."
Convince us.
(chuckling)
- No, all all right, sure, I will.
All right, so I'll start with,
so at places like Chicago,
I used to work for Yale,
I go to all these meetings
with the other Ivy deans.
At Chicago, I get about 300 kids
with perfect SATs apply every year
and we reject 60% of them.
Now that's supposed to make you feel good.
If you're online, don't freak out.
This is supposed to make you feel good.
It basically says that the testing
is only one piece of holistic review
and we care about your
grades and your activities
and your essays.
In fact, the vast
majority of my applicants
are more than qualified.
I have about 35,000 applicants,
30,000 of them would do
really well at UChicago
and when you get down to the last 10,000,
essentially, academically,
they're identical.
Everybody has got good
grades, good testing,
put things together
and when you get down to the last 5,000,
essentially I could kill
everyone in the freshmen class
and replace them with the wait list
and nobody would know the difference.
No, I'm kidding, I would never do that.
- Jim, be careful,
people might--
(laughs softly)
- We're all ready of
the applicants, is great
and that's not what differentiates you.
That's not what makes
you a UChicago student.
What makes you a UChicago student
or what you put into the essays
and how you respond and
the kind of person you are
in your love of learning
and if that comes through
in the application,
then we admit you.
- And, actually--
- Don't ever kill somebody
Sal, that was a joke.
- I know, you're one of the
nicest of people I know so,
yeah Jim does not do any killing.
One thing, you just touched on that,
put in your essays, that authenticity,
that's something we talk a lot about.
I love your insider's point of view
of how you spot authentic versus
inauthentic applications.
- Sure, so one of the things you'll hear
from almost any of the
highly selective deans
is that everything kinda holds together.
So the student's voice that
you hear in their first essay,
which is about kind of who they are,
with the background, what they believe in,
that that voice will then
carry on in their second essay,
which is typically unique to each school.
So we have our zany UChicago prompts
and the voice and the kind of
person you're meeting there
will be in the second essay,
they'll be in the third one,
which is, why do you
want to go to my school?
Why are you a good fit for you to Chicago?
And then if the voice is
consistent across all of those
and the kind of kid you're hearing,
the teacher recommendations
will reinforce that same thing
and so you can really tell
when somebody else has been involved
and so if I had one strong piece of advice
for all the families listening
and students listening,
it's don't let adults get
involved in writing your essays.
We can smell them a mile away.
You should sound like a 17 year old,
not a 41 year old lawyer.
And so, all the work,
the whole application should
kind of tell the same story
and a story of the kind of
kid you want on your campus.
Did that,
make sense?
- That's super helpful.
If you wanna share at any point,
I'd love to hear stories of applications
that were clearly written
by the 41 year old lawyer versus...
(laughs)
- Oh my God.
I had this one that I really just...
So I have one where it
was from another school
but their Dean and I were talking
and it was like, "I was
on their campus and,
"the only thing buzzing more than the bees
"was me at all the
academic opportunities,"
and I was like, no 17 year old
would ever write like that.
But on the flip side,
I will never forget
this one wonderful essay
that I read from a girl
that I referred to as the cannibal essay,
where she was at an all girls
Catholic school in California
and our essay prompt that
year was cats and dogs,
monteques and capulets,
auto bots and decepticons.
There are two kinds of people
in this world, what are they?
And she wrote about how
there was an earthquake
and they were all trapped,
how she would divide the student body
into those students she would eat
and the students she would not eat
and it was hysterical and funny
and something clearly only
a 17 year old would write
and the last part was,
"And so, it's not whether
they're juicy and succulent,
"it's whether they're interesting
"and that's why I would eat them
"and that's why I wanna go to UChicago
"to be around interesting
people and eat them."
We admitted her and I
checked her roommates
and they're always alive
so everything's fine.
(mumbling)
It's memorable, it speaks to who they are.
- No, this has got a little bit morbid
on some of these points
but I think your point
is exactly right that,
these things that are quirky,
that aren't a template,
that show clear creativity
definitely stand out
clearly for you.
Did we make the Jim
Nondorfs of the world smile
and remember that,
seems like a pretty good indicator.
So a lot more questions here from YouTube.
Aditya Gupta asks,
how has the inability to compete in sports
change in standardized testing
along with change in access
to extracurricular activities,
affecting the admissions process?
- Oh, that's a great question
because, well, it falls
into two categories.
So first there's like the athletes
who thought or are hoping to be recruited
and you should not worry
because the coaches have,
you're gonna be submitting testing.
I mean, videos,
some coaches may reach out to you
and ask you to video yourself
doing certain activities,
whether it's how fast you run
or agility drills and things like that.
The varsity coaches will
lead you along the way
and the process for getting that started
is pretty much the same for everybody.
You go online to the schools
you're interested in,
you go to the websites of
the athletic departments,
the specific team that you're interested
and they will,
there's a form for you
to fill out that says,
"I'm interested,"
and they ask you all the details.
I can bench press this
much, run this fast,
whatever the case might be.
So outside of being a recruited athlete,
what you do,
whatever you were doing,
we will take it that,
we kinda look at it and say,
"Well, they probably would have done that
"this last spring,"
and whether you were
an athlete or a singer
or you do community service,
you take care of an
elderly relative, you work,
there's nothing wrong with working.
Whether you're thespian, it doesn't...
That what you specifically
do doesn't matter.
What matters is that you're
passionate about something,
that you were engaged
in it, that you like it,
that you learn from it,
that you learn teamwork
and that can be done in many ways.
And the fact that you had one season off
is not gonna make an impact at all.
Please do not worry about that.
Every time I give talks,
I was giving one right before
the stay at home orders
with Stu Schmill who is a wonderful guy
and one of my best friends at MIT.
And he was saying how,
that we talk about this and we say,
there is no set of things
that everybody has to check
to get in.
If you didn't do community
service, we're like,
"Ooh, they must be killing
baby seals at night."
We don't think that.
It's not what you don't
do, it's what you do
that we're interested in
and so really try not to worry about
what you're missing, just
engage in something else.
- No, Jim, you're infectious.
You make me wanna apply to college.
(laughs)
- Awesome, we would take you in a second.
Now I know it.
- So we're getting a whole
series of questions here
that are dealing with COVID from Facebook.
Aditi Daga, do you think that trends
for the class of '21 will
continue for future classes?
What changes do you see for '22 onwards.
From Facebook, Carolyn Khan Sorkin asks,
if many of the high
school class of '20 kids
take a gap year, how will
this affect admissions,
I guess for wait list this
year and for next year's class?
- Well, there are a lot of things there,
so why don't I,
I'll give you some of the...
We're in unchartered
territory to be very honest.
Who knows what's going to happen.
I'll give you one of the
things that I am expecting.
So right now, we don't have any more kids
asking to take a gap
year than we've ever had.
We always have about
15, 20 this time of year
and they're doing really
cool and exciting things
that I want them to do it.
In terms of what things
are gonna take place.
So here's my theory on this
and I'd love to hear
your thoughts on, Sal.
So, maybe it's 15, 20 years ago,
all of a sudden everyone realized
it's a global world
and we should have study abroad programs.
Maybe it was longer ago
but really everybody
jumped on to study abroad
because you needed to know
that there are other cultures
and engage them and it has
become an important part
of every school's academic
kind of a program.
And we are learning a lot
about what is useful in online teaching
and I could imagine over the years ahead
that there would be a reason
to have online virtual classes
even during your four years
with no other external pushes
but because when you graduate,
you are going to need to
know how to do these things,
how to be self directed,
how to sit and listen to
a video for 45 minutes
and pull out the important things.
It's what you're gonna do if
you work for Goldman Sachs,
it's what you're gonna do
if you become a teacher,
a lawyer, it doesn't matter.
And so I think the skills
that students will need in the future,
that online education
could be a part of that,
just like study abroad is.
I don't think it's gonna be all online
and I think you get enormous value
in our residential four year model
but I do think that
there's always something
you can learn in every crisis.
In every crisis, in every war,
something comes up.
We wouldn't have had penicillin
if there weren't a war.
These challenges create opportunities.
I know I can say for my own
area, college admissions
that we are going to continue
offering virtual activities,
online activities, the
ability for students to...
We're creating a jukebox,
essentially a jukebox.
All of the videos of classes that we have
and there will be more
opportunities for students
because of this crisis
than there were in the past
and it will be more available to students
of also socioeconomic backgrounds.
It is great that a student can
actually get more information
about Chicago today than
they could've in the past
and all of it is free.
They only basically have to go online
as opposed to a hotel
room, a flight to Chicago
and those things.
So there's a lot of benefit
that's going to come out of this.
It's hard to see that now
but I really do believe that.
- And related to that, I know
your focus is on admissions
but I'm sure you're a part
of the broader conversation
at the university.
How is the university thinking
about contingency planning
for this back to school,
or if the virus picks back up?
- Sure, so every school
is thinking about this,
I can tell you that.
One of the huge values we have at Chicago
is that we're also are part of
a multi-billion dollar hospital,
the UChicago medical center
and working with the epidemiologists,
we are learning a lot about,
how do you operate in the
midst of the epidemic?
How do you make sure that
doctors don't get sick?
How do you make sure
nurses don't get sick?
All of the important
aspects of social distancing
and using what kind of
masks and things like that
and we're looking at how
do we take that expertise
and that learning and
leverage it into the fall.
So our first and highest goal
will be to make sure that
our students are safe
and that they're back on campus
learning the way we would want them to.
Obviously you have
multiple contingency plans
where maybe everybody doesn't come back
or if things go terrible in the fall,
I'm sure governors of many states
will tell their
universities they can't open
but we are going to do everything we can
to be open and to be teaching
and engaging our students
because we don't want that opportunity...
This is important.
It's important for their education,
it's important for the country
and quite honestly,
this is what the university is all about.
I feel we're very well prepared for it,
thankfully because we
have a great hospital
right next door to us
in a lot of places, they
don't have those experts.
They don't have hospitals,
essentially on their campus.
Even places that have wonderful hospitals,
they're not attached.
They're in a different part of the city,
they're on the other side
or they're not even in the same city.
At Chicago, the medical center
is essentially the next
quad over from the main quad
and so we are committed
to engaging our students.
We're gonna do a lot of virtual things
online with them this summer.
I'm going to do a lot
of virtual things online
with prospects this summer
and my hope is that we will have tours
and our students will be back in the fall.
- No, that's great.
And obviously none of us really knows
what's gonna happen but it sounds like
y'all have a good handle on it.
There's another question
about test optional
and I'll extend a little bit.
From YouTube, Golden Bucket asks,
where's the list that has...
Oh no, actually there's a different one.
This is from Amy S.Morgenstein.
That's the question I
wanted to ask from Facebook.
Jim, what has been your
experience going test optional?
Do you ever miss the SAT as a tool?
And I'll extend it a little bit
because not only are the test optional,
a lot of school districts I know
went to pass-fail this past term,
who knows what happened.
So there's this general
trend that at least
on these academic numerical
objective measures,
you might have less data
than you typically have.
Is that true,
especially with test optional
and how do you navigate that?
- Sure, so I guess I'd start with,
you need to have some
kind of valid information
that comes in and the
transcript is great for that,
testing is great for that.
What I think test optional schools do
is we offer other opportunities.
So there are other ways and other things
that students can send
in, in terms of what do I,
do I miss it?
But to be honest, 85, 90% of my applicants
do send in testing
because they think testing
is a good representation
of their academic quality,
that's great.
In terms of their worries about
what else could they send in,
I think a good applicant
and a good application
and a good college search,
all start with the same thing,
which is, let me think about myself.
What makes me unique,
what makes me special,
what makes me a good fit for schools?
Then you go and you visit schools
and you learn about what makes them unique
and eventually I'm a big believer,
you'll get a vibe and
you can get that vibe,
even electronically
and you'll get a sense,
this is the right school for me.
And then you look at
what they're looking for
and you try to showcase those attributes
in your application.
I want to get really specific about this
on the testing piece.
So students, I sometimes
see students take the test
three, five, seven, nine times
and I am like, that's,
one, you look neurotic and two,
you should write it down as
a extracurricular activity.
You've taken it so many times.
Testing is not to be
taken that many times,
you take it a couple of times
and that's what your score is
and you can submit it if you'd like to.
The reason I say that is
because within a hundred points,
it just doesn't matter in the
admissions committee room.
I see students, a student
who's taken the test,
got a 1580 and then they
take it four more times.
One, it's a waste of time
and it doesn't reflect
positively on them as a person.
And so it really is,
the same thing with GPA.
Like the most worthless
piece of information
I get is the GPA because
I get it in every conceivable format,
4.0, 5.0, 6.0, 10.0, 12.0,
weighted, unweighted,
dasas, quintas, quartas.
Sometimes they just give
you smiley faces at schools
and we still have to figure out a way
to look at that applicant and say,
"How did you do, what did you take,
"have you prepared yourself?"
And in general, most of my applicants
have done very well on
their academic pieces.
What's gonna make them stand out
in an applicant pool like we have
and like my very highly
selective peers have
is what makes the rest of
their application compelling
and that, quite honestly
comes through teacher recommendations,
the extracurriculars they do
and in many ways their essays.
These essays tell us so
much about their dreams
and the kinds of students they are
and the kind of learners they are
and what kind of an impact
they're gonna make on our campus
and on the world.
- And, we talked about the
kids who do submit the test.
There's that, as you mentioned,
10 to 15% who for whatever
reasons might not.
One, how do you view that
and how are they able to show
at least on the academic side
that they can be in the
same academic environment
as those students who are
scoring very well on these tests.
- Sure, so some of them
will actually take,
spend a lot of time on Khan Academy
and I can see that they
have acquired the skills.
That's another excellent
way to validate your grades
in high school is by doing
work on Khan Academy.
That's like, not an easy one,
one that shows me two things,
one, mastery but even more important,
it shows me work ethic, persistence.
The kids who are not
naturally good at math
but keep plugging away at it,
that's a great skill to have.
So that's one set.
I would also say there's
another set of students
for whom both the full test score
is not as relevant to what
they're planning to do
when they get to UChicago or many schools.
Great example, art history.
I can have an applicant who puts together
this amazing art history application
and they've done all of this work
and they write these amazing essays
and you can see they are
gonna get a PhD in art history
and probably change a field
and the fact that they have a 600 maybe,
on their math SAT section,
it doesn't matter to me.
I don't need to know and it tells me that,
what I need to know is can they do
the match requirement at UChicago.
I can look at their
transcript and it says,
they have a B+ in AP Calculus.
Sold, you are gonna be a
great UChicago art historian.
- That's super useful
and I guess related to that from Facebook,
I have this question from Maroom Hammoud
who asks, how to guide our kids
to the most suitable college
or path in their higher education
and I'll just add to that,
there tends to sometimes be an obsession
with the UChicago's of the world,
the highly selective
universities, it causes anxiety.
People try to,...
Their whole ego, their identity
is defined by where they go to school.
What advice do you have for folks?
- Well, so I'll start with,
there is no be-all end-all school
other than the University
of Chicago of course
and in many ways,
please do not equate
your sense of self worth,
your value, your accomplishments
to getting into any
highly selective school.
That's not how it works.
Our process is not about
evaluating students
and saying, "This student is good
"and this student is bad."
This is an economics problem set.
I have a limited number
of spaces for students
and I have many more
wonderful, amazing students
that I would love to take
than I can actually take
and have on campus.
I want you to know that
admissions officers
become very attached to their applicants.
Sometimes, people cry in
admissions committees,
not me but sometimes they cry
because they become so
attached to these students.
And so, that's the first thing,
this process is not about placing a value
on you as a person or
on your accomplishments.
The second piece of that
is how do you go about thinking,
where am I a good fit?
And you are in a great position right now
because every school is putting together
a lot of ways for you to
do that from your home.
If it were me, I would
start at a high level
and say, okay, I'm gonna look at
three large private research universities,
websites and videos and tours
and attend a class online.
And then I'm gonna do that for
three liberal arts colleges
and I'm gonna do it for
three large public schools
and I'm gonna get a sense
of what the vibe of which ones I liked,
what resonated with me.
And after you do that,
then you can go and look
deeper into that category.
So let's say you looked at, UChicago
into a much less positive
and totally inferior schools
like Harvard and Princeton.
And then you visit the
three of our schools
and you say, "Wow, I really
like research universities."
Well, then you can look
at other fine institutions
like Stanford and Yale and everybody else
but it's getting a sense of
what's a good fit for you
at the beginning.
And then once you've done that,
that's when you start
the process of saying,
why would they want me?
Why am I a good fit for them?
And it takes a little self
evaluation and examination
and then you choose a nice,
balanced college list,
which has some schools
that are highly selective
and some that are selective
and some that are less selective than that
and some schools where you think
you're an excellent fit
and you apply to them
and I can tell you that in general,
everybody pretty much goes to college.
If you do these things,
you will have options
and that's what this process,
a good process will
leave you with options.
- It's super valuable.
I have this question from YouTube.
Aditya Gupta asks, Jim,
what happens if you come
from a disadvantaged school
with limited resources
compared to more schools
in affluent communities?
How do you stand out
with limited resources?
- Awesome, so there are many ways to do it
and they're all the same ways
that the well-resourced students can do.
Anybody can write a great essay,
anybody can engage locally
in their community.
What anybody can,
hopefully, if you don't have
internet access at home,
eventually, libraries will open
and you can go to the library,
your local library and learn a little bit
about these schools.
Many schools...
So we have a whole set of programs
for first generation students.
We have our Odyssey Program,
which is essentially for families
who have less financial means.
We have Fly-Ins, we do
programming for these students
with their community based organizations.
We partner up with
programs like QuestBridge
or Jack Kent Cooke Foundation
and these programs where we essentially,
if your school wants my admissions officer
to come and give a talk to you alone
or all of your classmates,
we have those options available
and so we are committed
and we are not the only school.
My peers are equally
committed to doing this
and then we set aside hundreds
of millions of dollars
to ensure that you can come
to the University of Chicago
or Yale or Harvard or Stanford.
We're a no-loan school,
so you can decide to come
and there's no loans in your packages,
you graduate without debt.
The average, for students who are on PEL,
essentially everything is covered.
If your family makes less than $60,000,
it's free to go to UChicago
and some of my peers have
similar programs like that
and so I would say to you,
don't let your current situation...
So I was a first gen, low income student
from Hammond, Indiana
and I went off to Yale
and that was because...
You make the most of what you're given
and quite honestly, that stands out.
What you do with the resources you have
is what is what will make an
impact in your application.
- I doubly wanna, triply wanna
underline what you just said
'cause I think we probably
had very similar childhoods.
Growing up, MIT was always the school that
I didn't even know much about
but somehow I wanted to go there
but I used to look at the MSRP tuition
and it's like my mother
made 16,000 a year.
She was a cashier at a convenience store,
I was on free lunch.
I was like, I'm not
gonna be able to go there
and it was my sister who
told me about financial aid.
And so to your point,
if you're, below 60,000,
not even where my mom was
but if your family doesn't make a lot,
you can leave University of Chicago
without, it sounds like with no debt,
which is better than the
deal I had back in the 90s.
- Oh yeah, financial
aid has improved a lot
since you and I were in college,
I have to tell you, Sal.
- And how is the COVID
crisis changing things?
We're seeing record unemployment,
there's gonna be a lot more folks
in that category unfortunately.
I'm guessing the endowments are down
because of the stock market.
Is that gonna change, financial aid?
- Well, what's been wonderful is that
at the top schools,
there has been a constant reaffirmation,
certainly there has been at
the University of Chicago
that the financial aid
and supporting our low income students
remains, we're committed to that
and that is not changing,
regardless of how things are going
in the economy and alumni
and our board have stepped up.
There've been major campaigns,
especially in the last year,
giving to our Odyssey scholarships,
which is the financial aid
for our low income students.
Millions of dollars have
actually been raised
since March to assist our
low income students in,
the current students in
transitioning back to their homes,
setting them up computers, wifi,
paying for their trips home.
That has been a major commitment
and I don't see the very
top schools changing that.
Thankfully, the government is also now
kicking in some additional
funding for that
through the Kira's Act.
I would imagine there will be more of that
if the crisis continues or worsens
but the bottom line is,
this is a fundamental piece
of who a place like Chicago is
and some of our other
highly selective peers,
which is, we are here
to bring the very best
and brightest regardless of
socioeconomic background,
regardless of cultural background,
regardless of political
views and academic views.
We want the best and brightest
and you only get that
if you're willing to put your finances
behind that commitment.
- That's super valuable.
And we're getting a ton of questions.
Unfortunately, we're running out of time.
Jim, I would love to have you on again.
Your energy is infectious
and I think, clearly people are engaged.
Maybe just a good end question.
Pierce Schumann from YouTube says,
what is the most impressive thing
that you can see on someone's application?
And I'll just extend it,
what advice do you have?
Someone's applying to you, to UChicago.
They wanna be noticed by Jim Nondorf,
what advice, what should
they do in their life
and what should they do
on their application?
- So the first and most important thing
is don't ask what I think
you should be doing.
You should think about who you are
and be true to yourself.
The best applications are authentic
and really, it's like this is who I am
and I like who I am and
you're gonna like who I am
and I'm gonna show it to
you in your application.
Those are the applications you remember
and that stand out.
The ones that, where a student is like,
"Oh, I'll bet they'll wanna hear this,"
or, "Oh, I should go do this activity
"because it'll look
good on my application."
That's not the way to
go about this process.
It is be who you are,
be proud of who you are,
put your best foot forward
and it does work out.
- Well Jim, thank you so much
and I love...
Every time I talk to you,
I think you represent authenticity.
You represent...
My advice to the students out there
is be like Jim Nondorf.
Don't be exactly like
him, but he is himself.
He's not trying to filter out,
he has no talking points.
I've talked to admissions officers
that are just reading, talking points out
that their committee has put together
and that's not you
and I think the same thing
is true for students.
If, you have a committee
giving you talking points,
probably not a good authentic application.
So, be yourself
and I gotta say, my own
application in college,
I didn't know what a good
application looked like.
So, I drew a picture and
I wrote this crazy dream
that I had and people thought
I was crazy to submit that
but it got me in.
(giggling)
- Yeah, well, Sal,
I can't say thank you
enough for all you do.
I mean, you're a great fan and
I love spending time with you
and really what you do
and how you are changing
lives through Khan Academy
is amazing.
So, I hope you hear that every day
'cause I think about it every day.
So, really thank you.
- No, Jim and I gotta thank you.
The love is mutual and
for those who don't know,
Jim and I were always brainstorming
ways that Khan Academy
can be even more helpful
for folks to get in college applications.
Jim and I were just brainstorming,
are there ways that students
could take screenshots
and show it to the college
admissions of the world
and it sounds like it
could be really valuable.
So we're excited about
exploring stuff like that.
- All right, take care.
Thanks so much.
- Thanks everyone.
So, thanks for attending
today's daily live stream.
I'll remind us, it's
Teacher Appreciation Week.
So I wanna make sure I do
get that call out that,
huge appreciation to all the teachers
and I'll say even admissions
officers in my life
and other people's lives
but I hope you all got a lot of it.
I hope we can bring Jim on again
'cause I think there's a lot of questions
that we didn't get to
but I want everyone to stay safe,
stay healthy and we will see you tomorrow
on the live stream.